so we've already talked about multiple
types of solids we've talked about ionic
solids that's formed when you have ions
that are attracted to each other and
they form these lattice structures we
have seen
metallic
solids
and we've seen thought about them as
these positive ions in this sea of
negatively charged electrons and we've
also seen molecular solids which is
formed from individual molecules being
attracted to each other through
intermolecular forces
now what's different about covalent
network solids is that there are entire
networks formed by covalent bonds
what we see here for example is a
network of silicons and carbons and this
is silicon carbide right over here and
now some of you might think haven't we
already seen covalent bonds involved in
a solid before for example in molecular
solids and this right over here is an
example of a molecular solid that we
studied in that video you have the
molecules which are made up of atoms
bonded with covalent bonds but the
reason why they form a solid is because
the molecules are attracted to each
other through intermolecular forces and
if you wanted to melt this molecular
solid you have to essentially overcome
these intermolecular forces well in a
covalent network solid the solid to a
large degree is made up of these
covalent bonds and if you wanted to melt
this somehow you would have to overcome
these covalent bonds which generally
speaking are stronger than these
intermolecular forces and so you can
imagine covalent network solids are
going to have higher melting points you
also don't see a sea of electrons here
so unlike metallic solids they're not
going to be good conductors of
electricity
but just to understand this point a
little bit more clearly let's look at
some more covalent network solids
so what you see here on the left you
might recognize as a diamond a diamond
is just a bunch of carbons covalently
bonded to each other and this is the
structure of how these carbons are
bonded and as you might already know
diamonds are the hardest solid that we
know of these covalent bonds the way
that they are structured can take a lot
of stress a lot of pushing and pulling
it's very hard to break it now what's
interesting is that same carbon can form
different types of covalent network
solids for example
this right over here is graphite and
graphite is probably something you're
quite familiar with when you write with
a pencil you're essentially scraping
graphite onto that piece of paper and so
this is what graphite looks like it's
these covalent network sheets and each
of these sheets actually are attracted
to each other through intermolecular
forces and that's why it's easy to
scrape it because these sheets can slide
past each other but if you really wanted
to melt graphite you would have to break
these covalent bonds and so you can
imagine to overcome the covalent bonds
and melt say diamond or graphite it
takes a very very high temperature
graphite for example
sublimes at 36
degrees celsius the silicon carbide that
we looked at at the beginning of this
video it decomposes at
2830 degrees celsius
this right over here is a picture of
quartz which is a very common form of
silicon
dioxide
another covalent network solid and this
has a melting point of
1722 degrees celsius
so the big takeaway over the last
several videos is many different ways of
forming a solid it could be with ions it
could be with metals it could be with
molecules that are attracted to each
other with intermolecular forces or you
could have a network of atoms formed
with covalent bonds